[Music]
imagine you're sitting on a recliner
chair watching your favorite movie on a
lazy Sunday and your mom calls out your
name and asks you to run some errands
you can imagine how difficult it would
be for you to get up and do the work
imagine you're practicing for your 100
meters race on this track and somebody
asks you to stop immediately within a
second
will you be able to do it what if you
suddenly ask to turn towards the right
will you be able to turn immediately the
answer to both the questions would be a
no you can stop yes but gradually you
can also turn but not sharply and guess
what it's the same story with every
object every object will continue to do
what it's doing if it's at rest it will
remain at rest and if it's in motion it
will stay in motion but what can change
this yes only an unbalanced force can
change this if it's at risk and an
unbalanced force acts on it it will move
if it's in constant motion and an
unbalanced force acts on it it may
accelerate or change direction and this
is nothing but the Newton's first law of
motion cheers the correct definition an
object at rest stays at rest and an
object in motion stays in motion with
the same speed and the same direction
unless acted upon by an unbalanced force
in simple words it means that the
objects continue to do what they're
doing unless some external unbalanced
force acts on them
we can also understand this using a
simple diagram if the forces are
balanced
there can be two cases an object may be
at rest or an object will be in motion
at a nonzero constant velocity in a
particular direction these can be the
only two cases when the forces are
balanced in the first case the object
will continue to remain at rest and in
the second the object will continue to
stay in motion as the same velocity and
in the same direction don't forget these
two cases will remain true only if the
forces are balanced in the next video we
will look at a few applications of the
first law of motion
[Music]